pourquoi je suis là romane j'ai besoin
de toi on va détruire tous leurs
programmes nucléaire
je sais ce que je risque fais-moi
confiance
sois prudent d'accord
ma source vient de m'appeler la scie à
Eva attaquer les installations
nucléaires iraniennes
on est exposé on part dans 15 minutes
le lieu d'extraction est une vieille
base de la scie à canard
ce que je veux c'est rentrer chez moi et
c'est ce qu'on fera
c'est pas la distance le problème c'est
ce que tu dois traverser
si l'un d'entre eux trouve mon argent
ils vont le vendre plus offrant tu ne
seras plus en sécurité nulle part
lève les mains ok
avant qu'il décide de tirer
je suis pas une espionne j'ai besoin de
nom on en a aucun
[Musique]
dis-moi ce qui se passe vraiment
les enjeux sont beaucoup trop importants
c'est ma vie que tu as entre les mains
secours
[Musique]
je suis désolé
vraiment désolé
[Musique]